ردوا على صاروخ الوحش بالإنكار
أما هم في كوريا الجنوبية
فأطلقوا أول صاروخ فضائي
ليثيروا بذلك شهية كيم لإطلاق
المزيد من الصواريخ،
لبعض من قواتها، فهل هو تكتيك أم وصول
محقق للهدف؟
أما الناتو فينظر المزيد من العمليات
ما هو سلاح موسكو السري منذ القدم؟
وما هي الوحدة الروسية ٢٩١٥٥؟
تحقق بعض تنبؤات العرافة العمياء بانتظار البقية،
ما هي الخطة التي قدمتها أوكرانيا
ديبلوماسيا روسيا في بعض الدول الأوروبية
(سيول تحاول إنكار قوة كيم جونغ
وترد بإطلاق أول صواريخها)
تقرير لوزارة الدفاع في كوريا الجنوبية،
يكشف حقائق جديدة عن الصاروخ الأخير
الذي أطلقته كوريا الشمالية ووصفته
(بالحدث التاريخي)،
حيث قالت كوريا الشمالية أن الصاروخ
الذي تم إطلاقه هو الوحش هواسونغ١٧،
لكن سيول أكدت في تقريرها أن الصاروخ
ليس جديدا، وهو الصاروخ الذي أطلقته
بيونغ يانغ عام ٢٠١٧ من نوع هواسونغ١٥،
كما أكدت الوزارة الكورية الجنوبية
أن مشهد تواجد كيم جونغ أثناء الإطلاق
ليس حقيقيا أيضا،
ويعد صاروخ الوحش هواسونغ١٧
أكبر منظومة صواريخ بالستية
متنقلة حول العالم،
بينما قالت كوريا الجنوبية،
إنها اختبرت بنجاح إطلاق صاروخ فضائي
يعمل بالوقود الصلب بعد أسبوع من إطلاق
كوريا الشمالية صاروخ باليستي عابر للقارات،
حسبما أعلنت وسائل إعلام أمريكية.
وقالت وزارة دفاع كوريا الجنوبية،
إن الاختبار جاء في منعطف خطير للغاية
انتهكت فيه كوريا الشمالية مؤخرًا
قرار تجميدها وأطلقت صواريخ باليستية
عابرة للقارات.
فما الذي يعنيه أن تختبر سيول صواريخها
قال وزير خارجية الصين: مستعدون للارتقاء
بعلاقاتنا مع روسيا (إلى حقبة جديدة)
بينما أكد وزير الخارجية الروسي سيرغي
لافروف الأربعاء بأن موسكو وبكين
تقودان العالم نحو نظام "أكثر عدلا"،
خلال أول زيارة له إلى الحليف الصيني
منذ بدأت قوات بلاده بالهجوم على أوكرانيا
قبل شهر. وقال لافروف، إن العالم
"يعيش مرحلة بالغة الخطورة في تاريخ
العلاقات الدولية.. سنمضي وإياكم نحو نظام
عالمي متعدد الأقطاب عادل وديمقراطي".
ويأتي هذا اللقاء الودي بعد تهديدات أمريكية
(تكتيك أم غير ذلك)
أعلنت وزارة الدفاع الروسية:
إعادة تجميع القوات المسلحة الروسية
لتحرير دونباس بالكامل
وصرّح المتحدّث باسم الوزارة، إيغور كوناشينكوف،
بأنّ هدف المرحلة الأولى من العملية الروسية
في أوكرانيا كان يكمن في "إجبار العدو
على حشد قواته للحفاظ على السيطرة
على مدن كبرى، ومحاصرة هذه القوات
في ميادين القتال من دون اقتحام المدن
بغية تفادي سقوط خسائر بين المدنيين،
ولتكبيد تشكيلات نظام كييف هزيمة ستمنعه
من استخدام هذه القوات في المحور الرئيسي
لعمليات قواتنا المسلحة، أي منطقة دونباس
أما الناتو فأعلن أمينه العام ينس ستولتنبرغ،
أن الحلف لا يرى انسحاباً للقوات الروسية
من أوكرانيا، وأنه يتوقع «هجمات إضافية»
في أوكرانيا.
ويبقى السؤال المطروح هو
ما الذي أرادتها موسكو بانسحاباتها هذه؟
....
(السلاح الخفي)
جواسيس روسيا، ووجهها الخفي،
سلاحها السري منذ الأزل،
قالت صحيفة «وول ستريت جورنال» الأمريكية
إن المسؤولين في أوكرانيا يخشون السلاح الروسي
الخفي الداخلي، في الحرب الروسية
على أوكرانيا
وأشارت الصحيفة،
إلى أن السلاح الروسي لا يتمثل في القوة العسكرية،
ولكنه يتعلق بشبكة الجواسيس
التي نجحت موسكو في زرعها داخل أوكرانيا،
والتي يمكن أن تمثل تهديداً لا يقل شراسة
عن التهديد العسكري،
وبرغم تطهير معظم العناصر بعد ضم موسكو
للقرم إلا أن المسؤولين في كييف لا يزالون
يشعرون بالخوف، من وجود بقايا لتلك الشبكات».
(بايدن في مأزق)
صحفي يضع بايدن في مأزق
بسبب تراجعه عن تصريحاته
وقال أحد الصحفيين، خلال مؤتمر صحفي
للرئيس الأمريكي: هل أنت قلق من أن القادة
الآخرين في العالم سيبدؤون في الشك في عودة
أمريكا إذا استمرت بعض هذه الأشياء الكبيرة
التي تصرح بها على المسرح العالمي
وتتراجع عنها باستمرار ، ليرد بايدن
: مثل ماذا؟
ليرد الصحفي على سؤال بايدن:
لقد جعلت الأمر يبدو في اليومين الماضيين
وكأنك أخبرتنا أن القوات الأمريكية
كانت مع أوكرانيا..
(الأحداث والتطورات)
العرافة العمياء تعود من جديد لإثارة الجدل،
(بابا فانغا)، حيث تنبأت العرافة البلغارية
أن بوتين سيصبح سيد العالم،
كما اعتقدت بابا فانغا أن روسيا ستهيمن على العالم
وكانت هذه التنبؤات بعضا من مما قالته
هذه العرافة قبل أكثر من أربعين عاما،
ويبقى ذكر أن العرافة ماتت قبل أكثر من ٢٥عام،
وقد تحققت العديد من  تنبؤاتها إلى حد اللحظة،
مثل انفجار مفاعل تشيرنوبل وخروج بريطانيا
خطة من ٥ بنود قدمتها أوكرانيا ووصفتها
رووسيا بالبناءة
ووعدت موسكو بدراستها
١. إعلان أوكرانيا دولة محايدة وغير نووية
وخارجة من أي تحالفات على أساس ضمانات دولية
٢.أن تتخلى أوكرانيا عن محاولة استرجاع
دونباس والقرم بالوسائل العسكرية
٣. الامتناع عن استضافة قواعد عسكرية أجنبية
أو تدريبات عسكري في أوكرانيا
من دون موافقة الدول الضامنة وأهمها روسيا.
٤. روسيا لا تطلب عدم انضمام أوكرانيا
إلى الاتحاد الأوروبي
٥ تصاغ الخطة
وبعد ذلك يتم التوقيع عليها خلال اجتماع
بين زعيمي البلدين (بوتين وزيلينسكي)
..
وزارة الدفاع روسيا: القوات الروسية
تقدمت لمسافة ستة كيلومترات،
شرق أوكرانيا وتمكنت من قتل 60 من قوات العدو.
الناتو يتوقع المزيد من الهجمات الروسية في أوكرانيا
زعيم الشيشان قديروف يظهر في ماريوبول
مع قائد روسي أُذيع خبر مقتله
موسكو تتهم واشنطن بتدريب مقاتلين
من  داعش قبل إرسالهم للقتال في دونباس
مستشار الأمن القومي الأمريكي: القوات الأمريكية
المتواجدة في بولندا للدفاع عن أراضي الناتو
بينما قالت سي إن إن: أن القوات الأمريكية
في بولندا تعمل بالقرب من القوات الأوكرانية،،
فهل يستفز هذا الأمر موسكو لتبدأ بحرب ضد أمريكا؟
زيلينسكي يلوم الغرب:
لقد أخطأتم ألا تستحق روسيا حظرا نفطيا
رئيس بلدية لموسكو قدمت 3,5 مليون دولار
لهانتر بايدن و"عائلته".
وقال ترامب "هذا كثير من المال.
أعطته 3,5 مليون دولار وأعتقد ان بوتين
قد يكون لديه الرد على هذا الأمر.
أعتقد أن عليه كشفه علنا".
٤ دول أوروبية تعلن طرد أكثر من ٤٠
ديبلوماسيا روسيا، بمزاعم أنهم ينشطون
سرا كضباط استخبارات لمصلحة موسكو
فكيف سترد روسيا على هذه الخطوة؟
موسكو تسحب بعض قواتها إلى بيلاروسيا،
فهل اقتربت الحرب من نهايتها أم أنه تكتيك روسي
بايدن: حرب روسيا على أوكرانيا
تهديد لأوروبا ومنطقة المحيطين الهندي والهادئ
وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرغي شويغو:
العمليات العسكرية الروسية ستستمر لتحقيق جميع أهدافها
مصر ترفع رسوم قناة السويس من 5% إلى 20%
بسبب الحرب الأوكرانية
ألمانيا ترفض شراء إمدادات الغاز الروسية بالروبل،
كما فعّلت برلين مع النمسا خطة الطوارئ
لضمان إمدادات الغاز
كوريا الجنوبية تطلق الصواريخ وتستغرب
قيام جارتها الشمالية بالأمر ذاته،
والعالم يتساءل لماذا قامت موسكو بهذه الانسحابات،
وبايدن في مرمى الصحافة،
فكيف ستنتهي هذه الأحداث يا ترى؟